الرئيس الاوكراني ان الحرب الروسيه على
بلاده شامله وتهدد اسلوب الحياه الاوروبيه
واكد زيلينسكي في خطاب القاه امام
البرلمان الاوروبي في بروكسل ان اوكرانيا
المنتصره كما وصفها ستنضم قريبا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي
تخلصت اوروبا اخيرا من اعتمادها المدمر
على الوقود الاحفوري الروسي يجري تطهير
اوروبا من التاثير المفسد لاعمال
الاوليجارشيه الروسيه اوروبا محميه من
عملاء الخدمات الخاصه الروسيه لاول مره في
تاريخه يقدم الاتحاد الاوروبي مساعدات
عسكريه بهذا الحجم ولاول مره في التاريخ
يجري تقييما ايجابيا للاصلاحات الداخليه
في دوله اوروبيه تدافع عن نفسها في هذه
الحرب الشامله وفي الوقت نفسه تعمل على
تحديث مؤسساتها اثناء القتال نحن نقترب من
الاتحاد الاوروبي اوكرانيا ستكون عضوا فيه
اوكرانيا التي ستفوز ستكون عضوا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي الاتحاد الاوروبي هو
الفائز
[تصفيق]